all right so last week I was going about
my day checking my YouTube analytics
when I noticed something my most viewed
video once again is a really bad video I
made when I first started my channel
wherein I covered what I believe to be
the top 10 worst animated moments from
Dragon Ball super is very first apart
from it being a terrible cringy video
that I wish wouldn't be on the top of my
very most popular list it also just sort
of points the finger without doing
anything about it and so in an attempt
to prove to myself that I'm not that
person anymore today I'm gonna correct
what I believe to be the worst hour work
from Dragon Ball super 's 131 episodes
but that's not all I want to correct
each of these drawings in the style of
the animators that were in charge of
that artwork these animators weren't
given nearly enough time to correct
these pieces and so today I want to try
to see if I can mimic the animator
styles in order to see what these pieces
might have looked like had they been
given enough time to fully finish and
polish the product but how am I gonna
figure out which piece of artwork gets
my attention I'm just gonna post it
you guys procedures
okay so that was a bad idea it seems a
lot of people don't actually know much
about the animation process and on top
of all of that there are tons of images
people have been suggesting for me to
correct which isn't good because I am
incredibly slow at drawing so I think
I'm gonna need some help with this one
I'm gonna need to form a team and I know
just the guys for the job first up a
mediocre anime youtuber that tries to
validate his art school qualifications
by drawing thumbnails for his weekly
videos next anime age has an
unreasonably complex and comprehensive
understanding of Dragon Ball super czar
orkut animation he'll be the guy that
provides all the direction for style
choices in the video and he point-blank
refuses to draw with anything other than
a mouse despite having a perfectly good
drawing tablet on the floor of his room
and last but not least Trev
easily the best Dragonball artist I know
he can replicate super style with a
level of comfort speed and polish that
makes me both insecure and scared he'll
be the workhorse of the group
indefinitely the most accurate to
tadayoshi giamoro if you don't know who
he is ten yoshi tomorrow is the series
director for Dragon Ball super artwork
think of it as the guy responsible for
how the battle of gods and resurrection
F films looked and the dude is
responsible for drawing the designs
Dragon Ball super was created to use and
now that I've assembled my crack team of
experts and me it's time to start
correcting Dragon Ball super artwork
beginning at Ground Zero the battle of
gods arc now just to reiterate this
video isn't here to bash the animators
and artists who worked on the series in
fact it's here to maybe create an
example of what the series might have
looked like had the supervisors and
artists enough time to correct the less
polished illustrations this image is
taken from episode 5 during this
sequence of animation and one thing I
noticed while looking at the tweet I
posted was the large number of you that
might not be familiar with the animation
process in animation there are keyframes
and in-between frames keyframes are the
main parts of the animation the parts
that lasts the longest on screen and
they are drawn by key animators or
supervisors in betweens are drawn by
less experienced animators called
in-between artists they draw frames
between the keyframes to help smooth out
the animation and to link them together
in this video we will not be tackling
in-between frames only keyframes and so
the first infamous frame comes from
episode 5 and this first one is a doozy
[Music]
AJ drawing on a mouse because he's
insane volunteered to tackle this one as
his style is the closest between the
three of us to the supervisor of this
episode former Dragon Ball Z animator
now quítate an animation supervisor is
sort of the boss of that episode
essentially it's their job to make sure
the characters look like the characters
and to correct the visuals of the less
experienced hardest-working beneath them
on that episode in the case of Nell
quítate his style is much more distinct
and rounded when compared to the other
animators we'll be trying to replicate
today the original drawing we have
really no idea who drew it but all we do
know is that Tata didn't have the time
to correct it in fact when this episode
first aired it looked a whole lot worse
than what you might have seen in the
English dub or the show on the blu-ray
for the re-release of the series now
quítate and chief supervisor Takeo idees
actually went back and corrected entire
sections of the episode by themselves
the absolute mad lads but they never
corrected this one but don't worry we
got you there you have it fully
completed corrected artwork for Episode
five in the style of no quítate that's
one down nine more to go
next up episode 9
[Music]
episode 9 wasn't an episode that people
pointed to as particularly bad certainly
not like episode 5 was but it was
rougher on the edges to say the least in
this particular shot there are a lot of
characters in frame and so it's time to
put TREB skills to the test taken from
the failed Super Saiyan God ritual the
episode was supervised by Yoshitaka
yeshiva now this animation supervisor is
super interesting pun not intended
you don't want intended despite his less
than perfect style when drawing
Dragonball he was an invaluable member
of the team at OE when it came to
helping their already struggling
schedule in Dragon Ball super
you see Yoshi Tuppy is Shima famously
Solo animates episodes typically
speaking the episodes he worked on have
much much smaller staff numbers compared
with the others this guy works crazy
fast but despite his fast approach super
still struggled and the pressure put on
this guy is obvious when you look at
some of his output in super so
considering this shot was drawn by
Ashima himself myself and the team
decided we should try to correct this in
the style of the series animation
director can do shi yama mora think of
him as the boss looking over every
episode it's his job to manage the
supervisors or to correct their work if
it's rough or off month so this one will
try to be as close to the character
sheets as possible and trevor is nailing
it in this particular correction
Trevor's changing the faces of everyone
and the bodies of only Goku and Vegeta
the rest are considered accurate enough
to not warrant a correction themselves
you might also notice that once the
characters are draw an additional line
work in the different color is done over
the drawings this line work is often
present in animation frames to dictate
where the shading is supposed to go
oftentimes corrections can be as little
as fixing the light source on a drawing
you'll notice these lines all over other
animation frames provided by
professionals and that's this one done
in Dustin Trev I am jealous of your
skills and I wish I had them for this
next one next up is the resurrection F
arc episode 24
[Music]
the cut-up animation as I mentioned was
taken from episode 24 of Dragon Ball
super and the still in question is this
unlike Trev and AJ I am an incredibly
slow artist and figuring out how to make
this shot work was an utter nightmare
for me we thought about changing the
poses entirely to facilitate something a
bit more natural but I wanted to try to
keep this as close to the original as I
possibly could
within reason but let me tell you this
took me a long time
despite the fifth episode of Dragon Ball
super receiving most of the criticism
from the public things really were at
their worst during this period of the
show with some of these episodes having
an impossibly small production window to
actually create their episodes this
particular installment episode 24 is
arguably the worst look episode in all
of Dragon Ball super and it was
supervised by Yukihiro katana
unfortunately for kitano during his time
on the show he never really grasped
dragonballs art style modern or
otherwise and due to the already
crippling time restraints placed on him
and the staff working beneath him for
this episode and others to come his work
was made even rougher and worse to look
at and so despite not actually getting
to correct this piece of animation
properly I won't be replicating gitanos
art style for this one
but once again much like treads did in
the prior correction I will be trying to
replicate the character sheets supplied
by teddy Yoshi Yamamoto after going
through a number of modifications to
this piece some minor and some major
thanks to the suggestions of both Trev
and AJ I was able to finish this on time
and it came out with a decent result I
tried to stay close enough to the
original but also changed some things to
make it feel a little bit more natural
but unfortunately this won't be the last
time I danced with kitano in this video
but time to give me a break
[Music]
next up AJ with episode 30 this one is
pretty interesting which is a weird
thing for me to say about a terrible
recap episode but I digress it's
interesting because of the man who
supervised dit Dragon Ball super episode
30 was supervised by Masahiro Shima nuki
another great animator that worked on
the original Dragon Ball however what's
interesting about this guy is what he
did between his work on Dragon Ball Z
and super he worked on one piece for a
long time and that pretty much resulted
in him largely forgetting how to draw
Dragon Ball characters with some of his
work on modern dragon ball looking
distinctly one piece with the wider set
face and distance between the eyes and
despite his work on this particular
episode not being nearly as bad as he
once was he's still a far cry from where
he used to be on Z thankfully though as
the series progressed he managed to
regain much of his former style by the
time the tournament of power whirled
around during which his work looked
fantastic
and during this correction armed with
nothing but a mouse and what I could
only imagine is a whole lot of patience
AJ manages to complete his second
correction narrowing the face
considerably all right next up shifting
gears and jumping forward only slightly
landed us on episode 33 the first fight
of the universe six tournament and this
one was supervised by a lesser known
animation supervisor say so Toma the
image are they correct in today which is
also still in the show to this day is
this one and it makes me really
uncomfortable to look at so let's fix it
the votado and the legs of goku are
pretty good on this so i'll only need to
change the head and upper body for goku
once again due to time constraints Toma
didn't have enough time to correct much
of this episode and certainly not this
drawing
well most style itself gives his
characters slightly pointed ears he
keeps things pretty cute he likes the
heads a little more narrow than the
typical Dragonball wood so this one
should be very doable however one thing
that made this guy stand out amongst the
other supervisors was his thick thick
lines those of you that are familiar
with the show will remember episode 4
looking distinctly different because of
those thick lines lines like this have
been extremely rare in Dragonball but
have been seen in certain instances like
to go to the trunk section during fusion
reborn a major drawback to these thick
lines however is the amount of
time it takes to add them they aren't
added in post-production on a computer
they are physically drawn onto the
animation frame by hand and so leaders
say given the schedule the staff were
working under a toy for Dragon Ball
super the thick lines are one of the
first things to say goodbye and with it
a distinct part of what made Thomas
artwork stand out in Dragon Ball super
was lost so considering I've pretty much
finished this correction I decided to
add some factus to the drawing to give
it that authentic say as though Thoma
touch time for AJ's of asteroid skipping
forward to episode 50 we find ourselves
in one of my favorite episodes of the
Goku black arc the episodes animation
was supervised by yuuichi Kurosawa and
while I think the episode has some
really strong moments there are a few
patches here and there where karasawa
didn't have the time to correct the
finished product on top of all of that
the episode as a whole was incredibly
rushed requiring a lot of assistance
supervision the particulars shot we are
dealing with today is by Masahiro Shima
nuki who while working as a supervisor
on another episode during this time also
had to help with the artwork for this
one too his animation and artwork here
looks incredibly rushed and sloppy
compared to his normal output so
hopefully this correction will help
things someone another thing once again
touching on AJ's approach here because
he's using a mouse naturally there's no
line pressure and so once again instead
of picking up the drawing tablet that's
right by his foot he has decided to do
the line work twice to give the
impression that there's line pressure
I only recruit professionals but I can't
argue with the results as stressed out
and rough Shima nuki is now much closer
to Kara Sawa's aesthetic and now that
AJ's mouse is safely back in its holster
I guess it's my turn once again
Oh God okay I really didn't like the
look of this episode and to be honest
not many people did after episode 66
which looked amazing this episode 67
looked dreadful again entirely down to
the team behind it not having remotely
enough time to finish it as you can
clearly see by the creatures on screen
melting before your eyes the episodes
animation supervisor was a familiar face
UK hero k'tano the same guy who
struggled with the tight schedule
episode 24 has the same fate here and
unfortunately he really hasn't fully
grasped Dragon Ball super zart style
which unfortunately results in this so
hopefully this correction will make
things look a little more uniform or at
the very least closer to the character
sheets however despite this being the
second time Cattano features in this
video it unfortunately will be the last
one
- as once the terment of power came
around UK hero katana was demoted back
to a key animator and to be honest I
think that was probably for the best his
movement and animation has never been
bad just his character likeness under
the tight schedule he works much better
when being corrected in my opinion by
another Dragon Ball supervisor but poor
guy regarding the image I'm working on I
decided to rework Goku and Vegeta but
I'm not gonna touch the people in the
background low detail and background
characters isn't an issue and is how
most shows operate after a considerable
amount of time I finished both Goku and
Vegeta with the help and second opinions
of AJ and Trev guiding my hand to the
finish line and with this one done I
guess it's time to jump into the
tournament of power with Trent
[Music]
after a string of great looking episodes
eventually we all knew it had to give
way and episode 1 1 9 was yet another
example of supers atrocious schedule
putting ridiculous strain on its artists
typically as has been the case so far an
episode would only have one animation
supervisor overseeing a bunch of key
animators however in the case of this
episode there are four animation
supervisors and boy does it show for
this particular section with Gohan -
Toma Ono supervised the artwork what's
even more interesting is that within
this code of animation Otto's corrected
the face of Gohan on everything except
the last bit so I guess trebs gonna have
to do it for him ona's artwork encourage
or likeness is actually quite strong so
I think sticking to the character sheets
for this one makes the most sense
instead of trying to replicate a style
like the other ones in the original
Gohan's face needed to be altered as
well as his arms so here it is a fully
finished and corrected Gohan in the
style of tattoo Yoshi Yamamoto and just
like that it's my turn again
this one is bizarre to me coming
straight out of episode 123 we see a
really weird drawing of Vegeta covered
in an aura that almost looks like it's
trying to hide the fact that he has a
massive wonky eye the episode itself was
supervised for Osama Ishikawa who is by
all accounts quite close to the
character sheets with a few notable
differences here and there but even with
massive time constraints I refuse to
believe that
Ishikawa drew this it seems like way too
important of a moment to leave look this
bad but who knows all I know is that I'm
not giving him a wonky eye and I'm gonna
try my best to replicate Ishikawa style
here the entire thing was relatively
easy to draw the major changes I made
were to the face and shoulders I tried
to stop him from being so hunched over
and once again I fixed his wandering eye
additionally thanks to the critiques of
both AJ and Trevor I was able to fix the
minor details that make Ishikawa style
distinct fat ears with angular details
on the inside as well as straight
angular eyes other than that is just
hiding up on the light sources and
making sure everything is in its
preferred place and yeah that's Super
Saiyan blue or Vegeta hopefully this is
an improvement but that brings us to our
final correction and trebs gonna do the
honors episode 129 despite looking
largely okay this episode by all
accounts was a manic situation just
beneath the surface
the animation supervisor was Luigi
karasawa who even supplied some of his
own animation to the episode and it's
some of my favorite stuff from ultra
instant Goku but that couldn't save this
episodes aesthetics completely this shot
of UI Goku is completely owned corrected
and rough possibly from an animator
scrambling to get his work done on time
this episode looks as consistent as it
does only because half of the run time
consists of Bank or reused animation
reused or Bank animation is the
animation that would have been created
for an earlier episode but was
repurposed facilitate this episode's
needs thankfully this close-up of UI
Goku is a rather simple fix the goal of
this particular correction is to forget
closer to Kurosawa style which can be
seen throughout the entire episode and I
think this correction helps bring this
drawing in line with that aesthetic in
this video myself AJ and Trev spent our
time this week correct in the work of
other talented artists ten drawings in
total but what we didn't show you was
how long each drawing took us to create
keep in mind that we are working without
massive time constraints using
oftentimes the reference of the original
image to carry some of the work and we
are only working on a single frame the
animators that worked on these had to
produce hundreds of these drawings from
scratch with virtually no time at all
the average episode of Dragon Ball super
will contain between three thousand five
hundred and five thousand unique
drawings all prepared by these artists
my hope with this video is to point out
that there are real human beings
genuinely trying their very best to do
their job well under harrowing
circumstances speaking as an artist
myself I can't imagine how awful it must
have felt to be under that sort of time
constraint to create artwork for an
extremely popular property only to have
the entire world laughs at your efforts
and regrettably I was part of that
problem too so I'd like to take this
opportunity to say I'm sorry I would
like to thank Trev for supplying some
incredible artwork for this project and
I would like to thank AJ for the same as
well as providing the vast majority of
information in this video
they are both extremely talented and you
can find their social media in the
description down below go follow them
but that will do it for this week guys I
hope you enjoyed the video I'll see you
all next week and thank you so much for
watching
in between spam pausing and zooming in
claims that this was episode 5 tear and
call the animators to be fired this is
such disgusting and embarrassing
behavior and it's not even close to
reality if this issue stop
[Music]